I probably would say I'm a voice I'm
somebody who is using my own voice on
behalf of people who don't have much of
a voice those who don't have a lot of
power in this world particularly people
with hiv/aids and orphans and of all the
vulnerable people in the world the most
vulnerable our little girls and little
girls who are growing up without parents
really are at the mercy of society so I
feel like I am a voice for those two
groups in particular I can walk into a
hut or a hospital ward or a very very
poor home and walk in and not
necessarily bring gifts I there's an
urge at the beginning I suppose when I
first started doing what I'm doing to
bring something to somebody to bring a
gift to bring money to bring you know
basket full of toys or something now if
i bring anything i might bring some food
but what i have found great joy is in
just showing up just walking into
somebody's out someone else's house who
feels very alone who feels forgotten who
feels neglected who feels abandoned and
to sit down I to I put my arms around
them hold the child in my arms and just
know for that moment even that moment in
time my being with them my presence has
reminded them that they're not alone
there is tremendous joy